Salut Romain, ça v... ça va pas donc apparemment...
Qu'est-ce qu'il t'arrive ?
Romain : J'ai regardé les commentaires Youtube...
Aaaah, mais tu sais bien qu'il faut jamais faire ça
ça parlait de quoi ?
Romain : Ils parlaient de moi !
Aie...
*Générique de Dans Ton Corps* (Musique rock)
Vous avez été un certains nombre à me faire remarquer que je perdais mes cheveux
*Bruit d'appareil photo* Juste là, sur le dessus
Bon alors je vous en veux pas, parce que déjà bah je vous aime bien
Et puis en plus je vis ça très bien
*Pleurs*
Mais quand même je voudrais vous dire deux trois trucs à ce sujet
D'abord, oui, je perds mes cheveux mais, vous savez quoi ? Et bah c'est une maladie.
Je vais vous expliquer tout ça après
Ensuite, bon, vous l'avez surement pas dit méchamment et encore une fois je vis tout ça très bien
*Pleurs*
Et en vrai, les réflexions sur le physique des gens, bah ça peut vraiment faire mal
Mais ça aussi on va en reparler après alors restez bien jusqu'à la fin
Donc oui, j'ai perdu mes cheveux. Enfin j'ai perdu des cheveux en fait.
Et vous l'avez remarqué aussi, j'ai même perdu un bout de barbe juste là
Vous avez vu, ça a repoussé, mais ça a repoussé blanc.
C'est caractéristique d'une maladie qu'on appelle la pelade
*Vieille musique* (Paroles : La Pelade... (x2))
*Vieille musique* (Paroles : Ça voulait dire qu'on perd ses ch'veux )
Donc voilà, j'ai une pelade
Romain : OH PUTAIN LA PELADE !
*Foule qui crie* Romain : LA PELADE !! LA PELADE !!!
*Foule qui crie*
Nan mais calmez vous, c'est pas contagieux !
Bah oui quand on sait pas en plus de blesser les gens bah on risque de s'inquiéter pour rien
Ça n'est pas causé par un virus, ça n'est pas une maladie infectieuse,
c'est une maladie inflammatoire auto-immune
C'est-à-dire que votre propre système immunitaire, enfin le mien... en l'occurence
s'attaque à votre corps, enfin le mien... du coup, pas le vôtre.
Bref, en tous cas il ne s'attaque pas à celui des autres.
Donc pas de danger.
Les coupables, ce sont des cellules de notre système immunitaire
qu'on appelle des lymphocytes et qui sont une forme de nos globules blancs.
D'ordinaire ils sont plutôt cools hein
puisqu'ils nous défendent contre les infections, par exemple.
Sauf que là, ils deviennent dingues
et ils s'attaquent à nos folicules pileux, c'est-à-dire là où se trouvent la racine des cheveux ou des poils.
Attention, ils ne les détruisent pas hein, ils les inactivent.
C'est une maladie qui touche les hommes, les femmes et les enfants.
C'est assez fréquent d'en trouver plusieurs cas dans la même famille,
et vous entendrez sans doute dire qu'elle se déclenche souvent après un gros stress ou un traumatisme psychologique.
Y a plein de témoignages de patients qui vont dans ce sens,
y a même beaucoup de médecins qui reprennent ça à leur compte.
La vérité c'est que la maladie elle est encore mal connue
et qu'aucune étude scientifique n'a vraiment réussi à établir un lien évident entre la pelade...
*Vieille musique* (Paroles : La Pelade... La Pe..)
*Coup de batte + Bruitage (cri)*
Donc je disais : aucune étude scientifique n'a réussi à établir un lien entre,
la pelade et des causes psychologiques.
Ça veut pas dire qu'y en a pas, ça veut dire que ça n'a pas été prouvé scientifiquement.
*Bruit de batte qui tombe*
Bon, mais comment on sait qu'on a une pelade et qu'on est pas juste en train de devenir chauve comme son père ?
Alors il y a plusieurs formes de pelade mais généralement la chute des cheveux ou des poils est très brutale.
Parfois, juste en quelques jours.
Ensuite, la zone de pelade est bien délimitée, souvent ronde ou ovale, même si dans certaines formes on perd tous ses cheveux,
voire tous ses poils, même ses cils et ses sourcils.
*Voldemort hurle* NAAAAAAN !!
Il peut aussi y avoir d'autres zones touchées, comme la barbe, dans mon cas, mais aussi les ongles.
Et oui, est-ce que vous saviez que les ongles c'est de la même famille que les poils ou les cheveux ?
Hein ? On appelle ça des phanères, vous le saviez ?
*Soufflement du vent*
J'me... J'me sens un peu seul...
Y a quelques années un rugbyman professionnel s'était fait pas mal chambré pour ses coupes de cheveux un peu bizzares
Jusqu'à ce que Benjamin Lapeyre
C'est son nom hein
il n'y en a pas deux
explique ce qui lui arrivait
J'ai développé une maladie
qui s'appelle la pelade
voilà
donc là les gens ont plus ou moins arrêter de chambrer
mais le problème de ce brave Benjamin
c'est que la pelade ça se soigne
mais ça se soigne avec des médicaments
qui sont interdits pour les sportifs de haut niveau
ça se soigne notamment avec des traitements par corticoïdes
qui sont des anti-inflammatoires
vu que c'est une maladie inflammatoire
ça se tient
corticoïdes en pomade, en
injection dans le cuir chevelu
ou en comprimé
la bonne nouvelle donc c'est que
ça se soigne
et que ça peut même guérir spontannément
mais la mauvaise nouvelle c'est que ça
a tendance à récidiver
mais ça se re soigne, mais ça...
pour finir sachez que en plus des rugbyman c'est une maladie qui peut toucher d'autre
animaux mais c'est pas les même mécanisme qui rentre en jeux donc ne comparons pas.
on est pas des boeufs
Voila benjamin la paire et moi on a choisie la meme solution